[Musique]
on
c'est un truc de fou le puy du fou c'est
magique il ya des gladiateurs c'est
énorme un dégât alors on porte toujours
bien la jupe est un orange déconner
[Musique]
à
alors c'est très simple le cours de
touax et en avant et en arrière comme ça
mais c'est ridicule ça va pas du tout
bon 1 tu te tournes voilà non tu te
tournes il doit y avoir vraiment un truc
comme ça tu dois vraiment aller
[Rires]
alors soit 10 dans la piscine est chaude
regardez l'arrivée marie sa tête on
dirait une petite pintade en surpoids et
alors oulalala passe à ton coeur ma
soeur tu vas cac est là où
[Musique]
on
en était sûrs et ont aidé jean dherse
main en filigrane
[Musique]
ou
[ __ ] y'a un truc à taper mon père je
sais pas ce que c'est
[Applaudissements]